bonsoir mâcha merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
comment expliquez vous cette nouvelle
flambée de violence après cette
manifestation organisée par le hesbollah
bonjour et jaillissent c'était un peu un
scénario qui était déjà écrit dès hier
soir on s'attendait à ce type de
violence
on avait des informations qu'elle est
dans ce sens qu on avait des propos de
l'ancien ministre
des finances ali hassan khalil déjà qui
faisait part de problèmes liés à la
stabilité du liban en cas de mise en
examen les actes de landas d'arrêt à son
encontre donc c'était un scénario déjà
déjà les cris il suffisait de mettre un
peu d'huile sur le feu
on a vu cette couverture médiatique
plutôt occidental évidemment les laisser
penser que le hezbollah aujourd'hui
était responsable et des tirs mais aimer
sur le terrain est ce que c'est vraiment
le cas
c'est confus d'ivoire c'est très confus
il ya des témoignages qui indique qu'une
personne aurait d'abord tiré et qui est
cette personne était présente au sein
des manifestants et ça va prêter entre
dione le signal pour l'embrasement qui a
eu lieu il ya d'autres sources qui
accuse les sourciers bananas et d'autres
forces qui a vécu des manifestants c'est
encore très confus ce qu'on sait pour le
moment c'est qu'il ya neuf personnes qui
ont été arrêtées par l'armée libanaise
dont un ressortissant syrien qui serait
l'un des concierge de l'immeuble où se
seraient positionnés les snipers
aujourd'hui pourquoi cette
son pressions de la part du us voilà
cette mise sous pression
en même temps du mouvement amal
intervient alors que depuis le début de
semaine n'a il ya eu une crise politique
majeure au sein du gouvernement n'y a
t'il avec la menace même de démissionner
du gouvernement en cas de poursuite de
l' enquête
donc oui je vous en prie je vous en prie
en suivait donc près l'enquêté gênant
pour certains et certains essayent tout
de même de faire dessaisir le jugement
le juge tarek guitare comme de
mentionner dans votre reportage
alors aujourd'hui la france marque sa
vive préoccupation et appelle à
l'apaisement
réitère la nécessité pour la justice ne
baissent aussi de pouvoir travailler de
manière indépendante et impartiale ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement
le dossier du port de beyrouth est un
dossier hautement politique l'explosion
du port de beyrouth est une chose et le
port lui-même était un une plateforme de
contrebande est une plateforme de
caisses noires pour les différents
partis politiques et le ministère des
finances en cela comme en sa qualité de
tutelle le ministère de tutelle des
douanes était fortement impliqué là
dedans ce qui implique également que le
mini d'anciens ministres des finances à
des réseaux neutres à lille connaît
beaucoup de choses s'il n'en a pas s'il
n'a pas également participé à cela
quand on gagne et même oui
mais
lui même évoqué qui avait 5 milliards de
dollars qui disparaissaient chaque année
du port de beyrouth
en 2015 ou 2016 donc ça même si on met à
part l'histoire de l'explosion du port
de meilleur les rootkits qui est quand
même majeurs il y a une grande perte
pour l'état le revenu et cela également
participé à la crise économique à
l'explosion sociale et économique qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui clairement que peut faire le
gouvernement de najib mikati pour
apaiser les tensions commencent se
sortir de cette crise
le gouvernement nagib mikati a passé son
état de grâce après cette constitution
il est coincé
s'il
persiste s'ils ne désirent pas à la
sphère du port de beyrouth à un autre
juge
les ministres sunnites et chiites pardon
menacent de démissionner ce qui mettra
fin techniquement peut-être à son
existence parce que en plus il est
rejoint par un ministre marada
s'il décide de poursuivre l' enquête
donc se séparer ainsi et répondre ainsi
et répondre ainsi aussi à l'exigence de
la communauté internationale dans le
cadre de la transparence et de la
réforme du système des 10 hier
nécessaire aussi dans la lutte contre la
corruption il pourrait obtenir l'aide
économique et ainsi un peu sauvé
l'économie mais il n'existerait plus
s'il choisit enfin d'arrêter d'arrêter
les frais et de dessaisir le juge ça
serait un très mauvais signe pour la
communauté internationale et pour
l'obtention de l'aide économique donc
c'est un coup c'est un gouvernement
aujourd'hui en suspens
merci beaucoup françois el bacha d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rtl france